do you watch a lot of K dramas uh
uh I don't know what a lot means but I
watch my share my fair share you know I
think
um Korean dramas have been doing some
things like really in a very different
way from American dramas for a long time
and it's great to see the influences of
kdrama now on American drama and
especially movie movie making and I feel
like Netflix is really like catching on
to the fact that like just on a
viewership level like everyone's
obsessed with kdramas because let me I I
know I've never seen one
you've never seen one yeah I've never
seen one so I wanna you just sold me
okay okay so I'm a Layman okay
I saw kingdom is that the one with the
zombies yes love that show that's okay
drama yeah that's okay Drama Oh yeah but
it's got something new style K drama
right yeah yeah but I loved it I thought
it was amazing what else have I seen
that's it squid games but that's not
okay drama
okay it is that's a gift yeah yeah but
like the the classic K drama is the love
story like the boy meets girl that's why
I don't have the love extraordinary
attorney woo all right so give me the
top three that I must watch and I will
watch it okay so give me the top three
uh wow that's a hard question I will get
I will give you the three that come to
mind I don't know
Daniel Daniel check it out okay
give me the ones where you think I'm
gonna like it check out e101 class I
love it write it down each in one class
think about classes it is it's a it's a
Revenge story yeah it is okay so that's
one I'm gonna definitely watch it it's
like Count of Monte Cristo oh I love I
love The Count of Monte Cristo yeah so
you know what level it's a great
Underdog yeah um Vibe is this true in
this room I'm gonna get that other two
but in the Monte Cristo the guy goes to
prison right and he leaps prison and he
reinvents himself right but is there a
love interest that like went with
somebody else's anime or something is
that an account of Monte Cristo I don't
remember that okay yeah so the second
one what's the second one so eight one
class
um the I think the the mother of all
romantic kdramas is a really old one but
there's one called winter Sonata and I
think it's even going to be hard to find
but it you get deep Cuts already yeah
yeah um but winter Sonata I'm gonna like
it uh I don't know see I don't know if
that's your jam but if you want to know
like no no listen Okay start talking
like that but you know I've seen every
Kurosawa movie I've seen every Sergio
Leone movie I mean I'm I loved um Dr
Zhivago like these long sweeping
romantic I have a long sleeping romance
so Winter Soldier
I like that one that's Marvel oh that's
good though is that a romantic I like
that that was the one the first uh drama
that I saw and this was in my like I
don't want to say like 20s and I was
like what is this I don't know why what
this is but I want to watch all of it
right now oh really and I stayed up like
and you cried
damn straight I cried like multiple
times multiple times right yeah yeah
Winter Soldier third one what is it just
Sonata what's yours I've tried to pitch
it to him Landing for use Crash Landing
my wife loves Crash Landing do you like
Crash Landing I did not see that one I
have to admit like because there was a
little no it's heavy on the romance
though super heavy on the romance
there's another one that well wait you
were going to say something that you
could just cut out right and we can cut
that out in for real life right if you
want but I need to know what you were
cutting out you know there are certain
there's certain things that we all watch
and there are certain lines that we have
where we say well I just wouldn't
believe that right about things oh I see
so let me guess right she crashes her
plane on the other side of the DMZ line
she falls in love with a North Korean
Soldier he's
no and that does and you don't believe
that I'm a little bit like could that
really happen like a big it was just a
win a win the gust of wind that kind of
took her over yeah you've never been
there North Korea have you uh I actually
did step foot in North Korea because I
was at the DMZ and so technically
there's that area that is
um you're in North Korea and is it a
special pass that you have to get in or
like a fast pass like a Disneyland
Universal you know you don't just say
you don't just say hey let's go to North
Dakota yeah no that is it is a heavily
Fortified Area you need to get through
lots of guards and you need to have
arranged this with either the government
or some tour special tour group but you
can go what I'm saying is is that this
is what I want to ask you right is there
any world that Daniel Day Kim and Bobby
Lee gets to go and just go to North
Korea and visit the sites I think your
liability
yeah I don't know I'm a liability yeah
why why me you're just general Behavior
I'm not gonna spit on a statue
a little wild I I would be I wouldn't go
with you like I would go with someone
although I did do this in Thailand you
know when you see so in Thailand don't
make fun of the King right oh that's a
big deal right so I saw the very first
Avengers I was by myself doing a movie
out there and um so during the a movie
they do a 10 minute
you know I mean um Montage of the king
so everyone has to stand right and I
didn't stand is that bad
well in Thailand it is I know but I
didn't understand I refuse to stand and
then at the park you're supposed to
stand still during the music and I stood
in a really weird way but anyway
um so you're right yeah I'm not going
yeah yeah um so what's the third movie
uh one going back to the Love Theme My
Love From The Stars was a really popular
one uh and that was maybe I want to say
like 10 years ago but that broke a lot
of records at the time as well I love
from the stars is it aliens it literally
is an alien who comes down to earth so
you've got to suspend a lot of disbelief
I don't care I get suspended hey and but
the alien is Korean man everyone's
Korean so baby dancing maybe the
audition from [__] commercial was
that
it was for that
yeah yeah but that's what you know
that's one thing that I really think
that you know growing up in America we
lost out on like when people were doing
Hong Kong movies in the 80s you had
people kicking ass Jet Lee Jackie Chan
Italian fat but we were watching in
terms of images of ourselves
was the exact opposite well when I met
him he had never watched a single
wangarai movie like ever okay but now
HBO has all of them they have chunking
Express they have in the mood for love
Fallen Angels like all of it I just
think you should he's a [__] genius
one car wide like you know and some of
the best movies of this era if not all
time are from him really well and the so
like there's great Cinema everywhere I
can't wait to see like where else we're
gonna find amazing movie making and TV
content you know because America does
not have a Stranglehold on all of it and
that's one of the best things about
Netflix and the international
globalization of entertainment
yeah it's it's we got [__] man growing
up like there was